Senator Schmidt joins us now with more
on today's critical decision great job
sir of course one of the frustrating
things is that this kind of thing always
takes so long I mean they knew what they
were doing at the start you heard it in
those remarks uh would you agree and I
think I with your Twitter we would we
saw that you understood that this was a
ploy this was not even serious that they
knew that it would be reversed
yeah absolutely and and I think it's
important to point out that this was
first of all this is a big win for
taxpayers and it's a big win for the
rule of law I mean you had there's just
zero Authority at all in the
Constitution or any statutory Authority
that will allow the president United
States with the stroke of a pen to wipe
out
half a trillion dollars worth of student
loan debt up to a trillion so it's a big
win for taxpayers it's also you know a
big win for working folks I mean a lot
of people paid off their student loans
or they chose a different path for
people to subsidize this this it's a
it's a fundamental fairness argument
number two and number three as you
touched on this is just a cynical Ploy
by Joe Biden to get votes and I'm glad
the Supreme Court saw it you know our
way and ultimately declared this
unconstitutional there's no Authority
for it it's a cynical attempt I'm sure
they're going to be up to something new
but today we should celebrate the big
win because it's a big win for taxpayers
in the rule of law yeah it sure is you
know what's amazing with this also is
that by doing this they take time
effectively to
kind of illegitimately educate the
American public that something's
possible when it's not and we've already
got you know we're all given the side
eye to the federal government because
you know they're behaving funny and then
the president United States does this
and people some Americans are going to
think well this you know what happened
and he thought we could do it this
doesn't this just make our the effect
the legitimacy itself of the government
uh make it even worse for the average
person watching this happen
well I think yes and I also think that
it's important what the Supreme Court
did today on top of some other decisions
they made whether this EPA case last
year with the major questions Doctrine
what you're seeing now thankfully is a
narrowing of what these unilateral
executive actions what the impact they
can have or the broader administrative
State our Founders created a country
that you spread out Authority you had
separation of powers these kinds of
decisions are supposed to be decided
with the people's Branch the article one
branch Congress because guess what you
can send them there you can send them
home you can send them back these
unelected bureaucrats uh you know are
exercising immense Authority and nobody
ever voted for them and so you've got
that piece of it then you've got this
unilateral executive action look Tammy I
think it's important to remember now the
the the Playbook was set with covid
declare an emergency you know you know
aggregate power and control they did it
with covid they want to do it now with
climate issues they do with student
loans so the Playbook is set we've got
to be vigilant here push back at every
turn because I think these are
fundamental issues for our Republic well
you you know what one way one thing we
really need to do is Senator Schmidt is
to have the Senate to have Congress
change the degree to which a president
can maintain an emergency status for the
country you know they didn't want to let
go of the covet emergency because of
what it let them do isn't that exactly
the kind of thing that needs to change
through Congress
absolutely there needs to be structural
reform for this with emergencies number
you you hit the nail on the head but
also look if these are such good ideas
Congress should have to vote on it sure
right if if you want to ban get if you
want to ban gas stoves put that before
the article one branch Congress and let
the chips fall where they may I got news
for you A lot of these ridiculous and
stupid ideas would never see the light
of day because nobody's going to vote
for them but that's kind of the point
they want to move this radical agenda so
that you know people don't actually have
a chance to vote on it and we've got to
put an end to that so one of the things
I'm fighting for in the Senate and this
was a case that I brought when I was AG
one of the things that I'm bringing the
descent is try to fight for this kind of
structural reform to reign in and
dismantle the administrative State well
that's that's excellent and that's
exactly what we need and the success of
just moving it we've seen that happen
because of your work thank you Senator I
appreciate you joining me tonight and
congratulations hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else